Amber Rose reveals that she's had her
first and last threesome I had a
threesome recently so this weekend I ran
into two good friends of mine and we
just got wasted we hadn't just got
together and it was cool but it was a
guy it was a girl and it was horrible it
was the word like I literally I'm having
sleepless nights there was no passion
there was no there was no like like like
kissing and talk and like rolling around
it was just after words I didn't feel
fulfilled I felt like it like I just I
felt gross so is this now something I
wouldn't try again I definitely would
not try it again having anxiety but you
said sleepless nights yeah I think cuz
it was such a milestone and like in my
sexuality that like I can't let it go
that was amber on her new podcast
Loveline last week the Dancing with the
Stars competitor opened up to eg about
taking over the iconic show from dr.
drew this is really just up my alley
just being a feminist and being very sex
positive and having people call in and
ask questions I'm very open with my
sexuality I don't hold anything back I'm
not judgmental and you know there's
really nothing that anyone can call in
and say that I probably haven't heard
already